you have a way of using your voice and
yesterday i was sitting there
without no distraction listening to
black like me and i have to tell you i
had
tears in my eyes because i felt the pain
friday before blackout tuesday i
called my manager and i was like eric we
really need to talk about at least start
the discussion of releasing black like
me especially in this time
come monday morning i wake up i've got
so many phone calls and they're like
we're gonna release black like me
tomorrow
and i was like there you have it
[Music]
do you feel now free almost to be able
to speak your
truth in country music i do yeah ever
since i
finally got over the fear of the
pushback
for me it's like the reason why a lot of
country artists
don't really speak on a lot of matters
is out of fear that they're going to be
cancelled out of this format and that's
the way they make their money that's the
way
they take care of their families and for
me it was like i've already hit rock
bottom i can't go any lower i'm just
going to speak my truth
and it doesn't matter what anybody says
because i'm speaking it in love i'm not
angry about it i'm just speaking the
truth
how do you define change well i define
change by seeing people actually
listening
there's been so many conversations over
the last
month or so seeing so many black people
and people of color
getting a chance to be heard and a lot
of times i feel that people thought it
was just a bunch of noise and now people
are actually
listening and that to me has changed
it's important that we have these
conversations we have to become
uncomfortable to incite change we have
to it's the only way
and that's why i've become free because
i want to see change i really really
want to see change whether anything
happens from my career
i want to see change